alex dominguez a democratic member of
the texas house of representatives and
more than 50 of his colleagues felt they
had no choice
but to flee the state for washington d.c
in an effort to sound the alarm about a
law being pushed through their state
house
that they believe would imperil
democracy this is
an attempt to stop people from voting to
make it harder for them to vote to
frustrate them
one provision of this bill would
criminalize simple mistakes by our poll
workers
who are typically retired teachers
librarians who give up their time to
help people vote
but a simple mistake by them could get
them a third degree felony which is
punishable by
two to ten years in prison that's not a
texas value at all
because dominguez and his colleagues are
no longer in texas
the house of representatives there
doesn't have the minimum number of
participants it needs
to pass the new bill among other things
the law would reduce the number of
polling stations available
and would empower so-called poll
watchers who may seek to intimidate
voters
on tuesday joe biden argued democracy
itself
was imperiled by such laws being
proposed in republican majority states
across the country
this is election subversion it's the
most
dangerous threat to voting in the
integrity of free and fair elections in
our history
and since their arrival in dc the texas
democrats have met with the vice
president
and i know what you have done comes with
great sacrifice
but despite the rhetoric from the biden
administration
neither called for what democracy
campaigners say is essential
if the franchise is to be preserved
changing congressional rules
so that two laws in the u.s congress in
d.c
that would make state laws suppressing
the vote illegal
can pass with a simple majority what's
called a carve out
currently without 10 republican votes
those laws aren't going anywhere
we're going to have to prevail upon and
make certain that democrats
in the senate understand that we're on
borrowed time in texas right now
even with a carve out though there's no
guarantee that all 50 democrats would
support the bills in congress
and that's why the texas democrats say
they came to d.c
to show a democratic party that
currently appears to have other
national priorities how much is at stake
as
state after state moves to limit the
voting process
the texas democrats say they're up for
the fight even if it means being
separated from their families
and imperiling their full-time jobs the
legislators
are paid 600 per month it's not like a
congressional salary
so we depend on our own income at home
to
be able to take time away and and do the
people's work but i'm here to fight for
them i'm
even here to fight for those republicans
who might be disenfranchised in the
future
should this bill become law dominguez
and his colleagues say they want more
than just
expressions of sympathy while in their
self-imposed exile in dc
shia britancy al jazeera washington